okay 2021 all the marathon
let's do this i'm joining
oh also hello to future people on
youtube
um before i join
thanks for being here i'm gonna
timestamp every game in the youtube
video so
if you're watching in the future feel
free to jump around
also feel free to time travel into the
past
to watch live
and then say hi to twitch chat
because twitch chat is so lonely right
now
they just want to have youtube friends i
guess
okay
let's join
oh another thing if i put this on
youtube i might have this video
sponsored so if it is sponsored
thanks to the sponsor
skillshare you probably know this by now
but skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of classes
ranging from so many different topics
including animation graphic design
business even lifestyle and productivity
now one class i've been taking recently
and really enjoying is called modern
meditation this class does a great job
breaking down the meditation process in
a unique and accessible way and has
helped me use meditation to think more
clearly continually self-reflect and
stay calm under pressure all of which
are great skills for a chess player so
if you want access to this class along
with thousands of others i do have a
special offer for my subscribers
the first 1000 people to click the link
in the video description will get a one
month free trial to skillshare so you
can start learning and expanding your
horizons
thanks again to skillshare for
sponsoring this video and now let's get
back to some chess
uh first game
savlion i'm berserking let's get a
stafford
stafford gambit time
ooh safar gamma time
oh no my queen
someone call an ambulance
but not for me
oh it's so fun
how does that happen the first game
though another game is starting
uh
i don't have time to savor that okay
let's research again
i was hoping for an england gambit or
reverse staffer gambit
but now i just have a french down the
tempo
okay
all the games
yeah that was very pleasant
this pawn hanging this pawn is hanging
so yesterday i was playing a lot of
ultra bullets
so it's gonna be weird to adjust
like back to normal chess i think i can
take this
if takes i take the rook
if that i take the knight
life is so good right now
i just moved to la and was super
stressed the first week i was here oh no
your videos really helped me stay sane
while alone in an unfamiliar new place
thank you eric i'm glad i could help
oh no my knight
yeah enjoy la i know it can be
stressful or intimidating but
hopefully
oh wow wow wow that is the rose and we
all know and love rose and stafford
gambit is so wow nasty wow
yeah so many wows and nasties
hopefully that's not the only
wow worthy stafford
that will see the stream
life is something in fact life's a dance
you learn as you go
sometimes you lead sometimes you follow
that's so inspiring
also chess is basically just dancing
with your pieces
it's just one
like
improvising
choreographical
performance
i really wanted to fork something there
also i should probably move quicker
because i don't have increment
oh i could have taken the rook
let's take a pawn
i'm gonna take the rook
and now
so on my bucket list
blue's dancing for years and i find
chess way harder than dancing
i've connected
but i'm missing
i'm missing a pawn
okay i've connected eight with that
with my king filling in
get ready for it
how do i not stalemate
i guess i'll play this move
it would have been more satisfying if my
pawn was here and my king was
somewhere else
that worked out nicely
okay two fun games to start the
tournament
i don't think i've gained any rating but
that's okay
i gained happiness
oh yeah i'll add uh nathanson
not only did i have staff or gambit i
had oh no my
queen uh
that came as a package
don't worry about what you don't know
life's a dance you learn as you go the
longer i live the more i believe you do
have to give if you want to receive
that was beautiful
also unfortunately no england gambit
trapped this game
but uh
we still have some gambit type position
oh no
i left that pawn hanging for a moment
there
i have to be a little carol careful
can't get too
careless if white castles and all i'll
be ready to attack
queen d7 g4 etc
maybe sacking someday
some way
castle queen side
it's risky but um
[Music]
again i just want to do things on the
king side
okay i'll add king's gamut to the list
yeah i should also mention like the
first several games i will be berserking
um which is basically when i give time
odds caught my time in half but
it uh it allows me to gain tournament
points quicker
i'm still probably objectively worse
here
but
okay have some tension
a5 was probably wise
now i have to worry about the file
but for time being i'm uh
blocking the file bishop's defended
interesting
okay i'm allowing rook 8
and i'll
do a delayed bond cloud
but material is equal now
there's still this pawn tension also
this pawn is hanging
[Music]
akd welcome back hey eric good luck
thanks so much something for 26 months
at tier 3.
i really appreciate that
so far i've been relying on skill
but at some point i will need luck
i'm just realizing there's this move
which
i mean after this move
i think it would be okay
now i'm just putting my king
it's a useful defender and block hater
of the pawn
queen b5 may be coming
77 quintillion
777 quadrillion
777 trillion
777 billion 777
777
777 also hi also quack
wait what it didn't say quack
ah
the number was too long you reached the
the syllable limit or the character
limit
it's so funny because um the message did
say also quack
blockader i hardly know her
oh but in this case the king it's a
what's the pronoun for the king it's a
hymn
uh am i meeting by force
i'll pre-move this move
anticipating a spike check
yeah alpha zero will be proud of me for
this
also welcome back to the duck
at some point in the stream i will be
turning into a swan
i wore this yesterday it was really
uncomfortable
but uh
it was also a mistake because i meant to
order a goose mask but i ordered a swan
mask
okay back to tournaments
hey three in a row
the berserking never stops
at least until i lose then maybe i'll
stop
i think you lost my gambit for the prime
sub
uh
oh i didn't add a sullivan gamut to the
list
well let's get another stafford
i'm i'm still inviting this move
yeah white's playing something
that's probably playable it's a little
bit slow though good luck
great content thank you mr potato
yeah i have a bit more development
more space
and keep developing
[Music]
i think i'll go for castle queenside
i play this to um prepare queen d7 and
disallow knight g5
in d4
e4 playable it might be
so here i defend the bishop
i still want the castle and then just
palm storm
attack etcetera
a second game
in a row i'm casting queenside
going for a sharper position
now one thing i have to worry about is
this idea
which
is not yet a threat
if white plays g4 then it becomes a
threat
actually g4 i can take and take
and the fact that white has played h3 it
makes my attack more vicious
because when g4 is played it's likely
the file will open
and i mean the eventual target square is
g2
the bishop the potential queen rook
battery
okay i'll add a few more things
uh danish or sullivan
okay let's keep expanding
ortho schnapp
scandi
scandi is actually uh it would start as
a goddess
elephant okay
anticipating this and
ooh
i always play king v8s might go for the
gradual build up rook here
and then g4
will come eventually
oh i really want to suck my queen
does it work
it looks fun
but let's be civil
quite kings gambit
quaid wait what does quaid mean
is that a variation or just a word to
confuse me
okay i gotta watch my time
or is it a misspelling of quack
oh it's a variation
i'll have to google it
okay so if takes i take back i'm happy
or i take here first
if push i push
and white does nothing i mean b5 i play
this
if white flags and i just win
without needing to do anything
oh no
someone in chat is begging you for an
evan
also
also swan also quack
okay
thanks for all eric
oh i was doing some research earlier
because i i wanted to see what sounds
swans make
and they make
you know what swans say
they say
oh oh
almost oh no
as in oh no white's king
okay that was pleasant
or oh oh my
queen
okay
and the attack actually carried carried
through the way i was imagining
is getting all the pieces
the diagonals the files upon storm
[Music]
okay
moving on
um
an i am sandwiched between two fm's
very high rated sandwich i love you
i love you too storm king
okay what to play
what's on my list
let's do a bucket list item this game
[Music]
hillbilly
okay i'm adding this to the accomplished
little billy attack
it's uh the fun line in the carol khan
oh
lock's not really accepting my thing
though
i guess it's still a gambit i'm down the
pawn here
okay so i'm trying to induce queen e7
it's my third game of road casting queen
side
i'm still gonna go for these uh
attacking ideas
also did i miss bishop i think i missed
bishop before there
which appears to just be winning
as if takes i win the queen
and if that i
take and now i trap the rook
my queen's defended so the bishop's not
pinned
also maybe threatening this move
okay
hillbilly attack wins in 12 moves
oh yeah okay steven gray saying what the
quaid is
weight is e4 e5 f4
ef4 knight f3
g5 knight c3
oh it's a quaint gambit
what do people only chest do
bishop g7 or g4 okay let's do a little
bit of prep
if bishop g7
[Music]
i kind of like h4 like h4
maybe i would play d4
i would play d4 yeah and then if
if g4 immediately
95
wait what is
this
what is this takes
oh i can take on g4 okay
wait what is this
g2
am i discovering like the main trap
oh john davis plays this
this looks really cool white loses a
rook
and the black queen is reborn
but after queen h5
wow this seems like a cool opening trap
so slow motion replay
white allows
g4
which looks really enticing because it
walks into queen h4 and
this is the classic line yes
most useless reborn queen ever ah yeah
the queen stock queen's actually really
stuck
if d6 bishop h6
de5
okay queen e5 or castling so white's
already winning here
i kind of like castling
because now we're threatening bishop b5
check
and if takes takes queen f3
knight yeah knight d5
okay i'll try and remember that
i'll be going for a king's rabbit from
now on
wait where's my tournament
is my tournament
okay thanks for sharing that steven gray
i feel like i've seen john play that at
some point
okay
things gonna be time
what are the odds i get it never mind
okay i'll play my uh my usual sicilian
stuff
provisional rated
i have to be slightly careful
okay that was a free pawn
[Music]
this bishop breaks or broke the pin but
it obstructed the queen from defending
d5
opponents realizing their
mistake
now probably suffering in pain i take
this
oh there's kind of a funny line okay so
after this i'm gonna take here
because of this i take here hey it's
merch oh no my king love your content a
lot keep up the good work good luck with
the 24-hour marathon
oh no my bishop
also the bishop is defended by the
prospect of queen h5
which is kind of cool
opponent sees it
okay so now i'll take
yeah i think you oh no my king
getting
some form of merch
yeah we do have coupon code autumn for
this uh
duration of this stream
also i gotta move quicker
i don't have increment
opponents like a decently high rated
bullet player
i'm up a pawn but it's not super simple
to to win quickly
i want to go for knight g5 and target e6
okay going for the double up
wow
[Music]
very bold move
okay now this is a triple up
this pawn is pinned to the rook
wow
[Music]
some fun sounds there
position is getting confusing i want to
take the pawn but bishop b6
my king safe
so
probably want to shift over to that file
i am baby imrozen thank you m rose and
let's go oh thank you
oh this pawn is hanging
i think the rook
rook here is coming
i'm throwing maiden one
but my knight is attacked three times
please take my knight
[Music]
oh that didn't really work
or is it working it might be working
c4 in the end so key five
check
13 seconds and no increment
no
[Music]
i'm so sad right now there's my first
loss
i'm sure
yeah i'm sure i had winning
other ways to win that
[Music]
who knows the lock though put up
resistance
yeah it seemed like i i was very very
close to mating around here
oh there goes some readings
thank you jabberwock
it's a dangerous thing with uh
berserking as i do lose increment
i thought i had enough time
good to see you on twitch
so there goes my winning streak
but still top thousand
also welcome silo simon
15 month sub
good to see you back
uh okay no berserking this is my first
non berserking game
i'm still trying to get the
quaid variation
also let's mix up the opening maybe i'll
play like a
a normal sicilian
or
i'll play bishop b5 check
also hello to mr kusha
good to see you
accident from florida
stopping for 17 months
trying to remember the
the prep here
like d4 at some point
i think there's some logic to d4 also
some logic to d3
stay flexible with knight c3
okay
i'll play d4
i'm going into more open sicilian
thank you tech tom
and kyle lee oracle
somewhat uh symmetrically pleasing setup
bishop f4 this pawns undefended
so it was uh actually both center pawns
were black
are undefended
if this i can play this
one mask video was a true masterpiece oh
great stuff as always are you planning
on joining any otb tournaments soon
ooh uh oh thanks for the words
there there very possibly could be more
swan videos to come
oh i got forked
so sometimes when you get forage the
best response
is the counter fork
it's a really feel good fork
and now i'll save the bishop
wait there's there's options here
let's save the bishop
i think the queen might be just getting
trapped
like c5 out of a5
and all the squares around the queen
okay i didn't see queen a5
now it's time to take your stream
hyper's
we'll see we'll see i'm not sure if i'll
make it for 20 hours but
i've made it for
[Music]
44 minutes so far
also welcome back can the carowind
thanks for being here
okay the queen should be getting trapped
so i can take take and bishop here
and then oh no black's queen
oh i didn't see that
but here i can take
it takes i check
and then i take
and i'm up a rook
let's go okay pretty quick win there
gain back one point
so i've won
what six out of seven games
i'm pretty sure i'm downgrading points
i'm down 11 rating points
okay back to berserking if i win i can
continue berserking
let's play no sullivan
playing frankie frank
top 900 now
okay
knight c3 was probably just pre-moved
uh i'll take
allowing white to take the pawn
after which i would take on g2
omg eric rosen
omg
omg it's eric rosenfan
thanks for being here
also what is this position
i'll play this move
oh no my pawn
play this move
and try and make things spicy here
it's been seven months so i guess i'm a
baby porcupine which are called porky
pets
also quills
wait what
i feel like a porcupine is when you
combine a pin and a fork
and pine
and you
porcupine
okay hitting the bishop
i'm actually liking the harmony here
the pieces are
applying pressure nicely
um this could be a fancy move
play this move though
it should probably start moving quicker
oh how long have i been playing you can
use the uptime command
47 minutes now
i did late join the tournament
which i feel like is a decent strategy
for these marathon tournaments
so white just uh yeah attacked my knight
but left this night undefended
okay how to make quickly
i'd have to open the center
opponent taking their sweet time
the chat is now in emo only mode
now this pawn's a bit tender
some idea to play knight e5 this pawn is
also hanging
this palm's pinned
[Music]
i think my king will be safe here
take my amazon box
oh thank you
i'll gladly take them mirkasoft
solving for six months with prime
okay so the king is uh is using the pawn
as a shield
[Music]
and as a pillow
it's a nice pawn pillow
oh i miss maiden one i was thinking
about playing queen b7 saying oh no my
queen and then mating
the queen was no longer defending
e3
okay that was nice
was bx
bxf3qxf3 north carolina two winning
uh
i assume back
oh back here
probably
yeah
some content eric
it's a good point
so takes takes takes king f1 takes takes
yeah
although if i played this maybe it would
take longer to win
because i would have less of a mating
attack
when i kept my knight on the board
the knight generated some
some nice attack and it was actually
stronger than white's rook
okay
got a nice bishop mate there
all right o'sullivan has been
accomplished
should also add like top
to clarify my earlier request the
challenge is to make a move so three
identical pieces could move to the same
square forcing the notation to need both
the letter and number of the pieces
i see what you mean
okay
that would require promoting to
some absurd number of queens or knights
also what is this
i'm i was trying to play the quaid
variation but
opponents not letting me
i guess we have just some
kind of gambit type thing
or uh king's gambit declined
okay reminds me of the grand prix setup
ooh
okay bishop's getting trapped black and
sack
generally uh in these cases
when i give away two pawns for a piece
like that
um
[Music]
in this case it's very good for white
because the king is still pretty safe
and i have an extra sized piece we take
those
yes
yeah time to substitute subsidize all of
the pieces
whatever that means
what would subsidize mean in regards to
chess
support financially
just donate to the pieces that are
struggling
oh as opposed to free peace
okay i'm threading the
the majestic pork
woman saw my threat
i should move faster
the rook wants to get involved
i'm losing a pawn
um
i mean this is looking really really
good
because i have
all my pieces ready to attack it's just
a question how to
execute
and now i'm probably threatening to take
it's still not super clear
i do want to take eventually
yeah now i'll take here
okay got the diagonals got the files
got a pawn on d6
a difficult position for black
very simple threads to take and then
take here
plenty of time
for a position like this
probably
probably moving for the kill very soon
i don't think buck can actually
stop black and delay the inevitable
wait how do i get out of the checks
i have to walk my king to g3
queen h6 king g3
and now there's no more checks there's
queen g5
i am threatening made in one
oh this is also made in one threat
so what's going to happen is black in
the resign flag
or get mated
or find a miracle come back not to lose
there was queen e3 i didn't see queen e3
until someone said it in chat
uh
i guess then i would have uh rook f3
oh should i do the thing
no i would need to under promote too
many times
okay
uh hey top 666
but more like 661.
playing carancho
i still want the quaid variation
hey first time chatter
cheering 500 bits
what a legend
x7j4y
appreciate that
okay playing a more traditional grand
prix attack
oh
yeah box walking into
one of the the old
i don't even know what to call this one
of the really nice lines for white
a lot of people in the past have walked
into this
after bishop g5 it's completely
completely winning for white
the problem is the knight's pinned
and there's no f6 because the pawn's
pinned
and now knight d5
i showed this once in the saint louis
chess club lecture
like this is the exact sequence of
sacking the pawn
queen h4 bishop g5
now there's two ways to defend the
knight either bishop here not here
both of which walk into this
i remember the first time i learned
about this line
i had the black side of this position
[Music]
it was really unpleasant
this was back when i was probably like
16 or 1700
happened in a tournament game
but then i started using it as a weapon
for white
the type of thing if you play the grand
prix attack it's one of the first things
you learn
[Music]
maybe after this game i'll briefly
share the st louis chess club video
you're making this look so easy great
content
thank you eric s rosen
easy peasy
so i could have taken the night for
something i'd like to lose epically to
you i want to take the key fine too i
guess
someday feel free to join the tournament
rex cupcake
okay let's find this uh st louis chess
club lecture
okay i can't spell but
google has corrected me so it's this
video
this was back when i was a much younger
person
2017
also this video has almost a million
views
that's nice evergreen content
this is one of my first lectures at the
st louis chess club
so i was really
i was actually really nervous before the
game or the before the
lesson as it was being recorded
i want to first say that i'm really
jealous of
john
because jonathan used to do the opening
lectures for the club
and i did an opening lecture
inspired by him
[Music]
wait where did i show this line oh here
we go
okay so
if we compare
the game i just had to this position is
very similar
if we go even a little bit further
or back
what do they show
[Music]
anyway i share a bunch of lines if
people want to watch that
i'll leave a link
it's a almost 50 minute lecture covering
lots of lines
in the knight c3 sicilian
okay back to tournament
oh ardabir says i feel proud playing g
takes f5 against you
oh yeah gf5 is like the the better line
um if we go
[Music]
like when so not this exact position but
when white plays f5 it's usually better
to take with the g pawn
to keep the light squared bishop
blunted
okay
moving on
um
go for a budapest
or
let's just play anti-london
go for the usual c5
knight c6 queen b6
this is not going to be a 24 hour stream
it could be a 21 hour stream
but uh we'll see i'm taking it one game
at a time
one move at a time
so this is still prep it's a fun line
like at the space advantage
um i guess that's a move
a b5 to reinforce
the problem for white after takes takes
so rook can't access b1
my bishop just prevents it
and now i have a nice idea of playing
bishop a3
to eventually trap the rook
and white's already
suffering
yeah this is one of the ways to take
down the london quickly like it looks
solid for white but then the bishops
you just invade
do some dirty work
first time chatter from
xjrs
asking how good would you say your
tennis skills are
i actually played tennis earlier today
against levy
recorded some videos
i might uh i might post a like a
highlights reel to youtube at some point
my tennis elo is definitely
less than my chassis low but
we were both capable of getting the ball
back
okay so this is a nice little fork
a file's open so
these pawns are falling one by one
[Music]
so that does defend the night but
loses another pawn
the knight's still attacked and pinned
and this pawn's hanging
so many things are hanging points
position
can you get robert has to commentate you
and levy playing tennis
it's not a bad idea
i have to call up robert
ask him what his rates are for
commentary
for tennis commentary
you might charge a premium for that
i think robert is playing in riga soon
i'll have to reach out to him at some
point
okay
so
up two pawns and now a knight and now a
bishop
life is good
and if takes i take here and then these
two things are hanging
yeah everything in life is free
now the bishop's attacked
i do want to hold on to the pawn
i'll play this move
defending and attacking
and preparing v5
also the rook is almost trapped
yeah that was one of the only moves
maybe try trapping this rook
or just trying to clean the pawn
oohs pawns attacks
defend yeah because the spawn's pinned
if rook here i play c2
don't take my knight don't take it
okay
i think i confused my opponent enough
with that move for them to flag
um
the point of playing this move was to
fulfill one of the challenges which
i guess i didn't quite fulfill but
the challenge would have been to
have something let's say rook here check
here
here
here
and then after takes
oh it just says knight f takes d4
i guess i would need it to be
how would i even do this
i would need my knight to be here
okay disregard the next few moves
someone wanted me to do a challenge
where
i i play a move where the notation would
have to say
so i guess in this case
the notation will say knight e6 takes d4
because there's a knight on the e file
and the six rank
so if you said like knight six takes d4
it could be this knight if you said
knight e takes d4 it could also be this
knight anyway um
that was a long explanation anyway
uh 435
i've only lost one game
41 points
back on the bus working streak
there is a prediction going on
i'm going to try and avoid looking at
i don't want to influence my uh my plate
too much was working again
what to play play benoni gabbit
now i'm playing the noni dutch
i did go through a phase of playing this
when i was uh
like right before i became an i am
i played this opening pretty
consistently
seven months
thanks for teaching us cool chess things
oh thank you jks 152.
the person is first has
164 points
oh that's a lot of points
also what i'm doing right now this is
kind of the ideal setup from this
opening
so i really haven't had to think too
much
before
[Music]
i'll just hold my ground maybe play g5
the file is opened
i don't want to play this move
and then the h4
okay so defending the pawn with the
queen and bishop
white's playing as well
the rook
how to do this maybe maneuver the knight
to g6
oh thank you people subbing
three subs in a row there
oh no i have to move quicker
30 seconds
opponent hasn't really used any time to
i have to play more aggressively
go into some end game
on this kind of hanging
[Music]
i gotta focus here
white's in trouble now
i'm throwing made in one
g4 i play h4
hey i won connect four
okay
got my my pawn worm let's go
thank you the black goose for the bits
that's nice on croissant
oh yeah i guess on croissant is kind of
a key move there
or on passant
or antepacente
only way to win a piece
it's a fork and then it's
uh kind of the deflection
reflection
removal of the guard removing the king
from guarding the bishop
that was nice
you